[Musica]
il futuro sarà disegnato da noi e lo
intendo letteralmente da me da voi da
tutti un futuro dove disegneremo oggetti
dove disegneremo servizio su misura dove
disegneremo la nostra vita è una
premonizione semplice no non avrete
pagato il biglietto per venire a
sentirmi fantasticare su che tecnologia
avremo domani macchine volanti robot che
ci servono a ristorante piuttosto che
umani che si produrranno da soli pezzi
di ricambio
questa è una cosa che possiamo fare
tranquillamente con un bicchiere di vino
guardando le stelle con gli amici giusto
quello che vorrei fare con voi è un
passaggio in più vorrei costruire la
mappa del nostro futuro con la
tecnologia una mappa con episodi anche
drammatici una mappa dove grandi golia
del business potranno essere abbattuti
da giovani davide con le fionde una
mappa dove chi non evolve muore è una
mappa dove una semplice idea può vincere
su tutti però per farlo
vorrei fare un passo indietro vorrei
cominciare a costruire con voi una linea
temporale per andare a identificare
quelli che sono gli eventi chiave che
stanno portando questa trasformazione
facciamo un passo indietro 2001 su un
brand of tomorrow un libro illustrato di
getty images che oltre a esempi bizzarri
come lo scontrino dell'aria che
respiriamo
il canale della guerra che mi auguro non
verrà mai a un capitolo molto
interessante brand schappert il pastore
dei brand in questo capitolo si ipotizza
che i brand del futuro non
sopravviveranno
se non comunicheranno col consumatore i
brand del futuro dovranno coinvolgerci
il brand e il futuro saranno vivi non
saranno statici ed è così lungimirante
da capire anche come si parla di dati
nel 2001 i nostri dati i vostri dati
i dati di consumo stati di comportamento
stati di vita per cui dati serviranno ai
brand per coinvolgerci teniamo a mente
questa parola coinvolgimento e facciamo
un passo avanti
siamo nel 2003 il pensiero di ari cespro
il padre dell'open innovation che in
questa stanza mi ha sentito parlare di
open innovation
alzi la mano
il suo pensiero rinforza quello che
abbiamo appena detto nel futuro i brand
dovranno aprire le porte alla
cooperazione esterna dovranno parlare
con tutti dovranno collaborare un cambio
di mentalità un cambio di paradigma
non siamo abituati a questi laboratori e
con davanti le guardie dove tutto si fa
in segretezza in segretezza per
disegnare prodotti e servizi che poi noi
compreremo completamente diverso e in
questa sua visione
l'unico modo con cui brand trarranno
profitti nel futuro e tramite questo
coinvolgimento e questa collaborazione
per cui scusatemi un attimo
coinvolgimento dati coinvolgo per
collezionare dati elaboro dati per
creare servizi su misura e questi
servizi sono quelli che mi fanno fare
profitto cominciassero abbastanza chiare
al 4 proviamo ad andare avanti in questa
storia immaginiamoci di essere in un
consiglio di amministrazione di un brand
con la stellina in mezzo alle slide e
rappresenta questo nostro brand e ci
facciamo una semplice domanda come
facciamo a crescere il pensiero
tradizionale
sarebbe semplice se vogliamo crescere
nella nostra quota di mercato compriamo
altri prodotti
no no se fossimo coca cola compreremo ne
state compreremo san pellegrino
compreremo tutti i drink che ci sono su
questa terra se fossimo de cecco
compreremo la barilla
semplice no ma poi ci sarebbe qualcun
altro che dice però aspetta un attimo
per fare profitto ci serve la supply
chain logistica per cui compravo le
fabbriche compriamo i trasporti comprami
negozi e questo profilo è quella che ci
permette di guadagnare però in questo
pensiero statico dov'è il consumatore
dov'è il coinvolgimento non c'è per cui
abbiamo bisogno di fare un altro passo
abbiamo bisogno di identificare quella
cosa che ha cambiato il mondo quella
cosa
quell'oggetto che ha catalizzato la
trasformazione
siamo le 2007 chi lo sa ti do un indizio
2007 2007
steve jobs lancia l'iphone e uso le sue
parole dice ci sono dei telefoni che si
dicono smart questi telefoni smart anno
le mail a nei messaggini mano un po di
internet però sono complessi sono
difficili per cui abbiamo deciso di
reinventare il telefono e siamo partiti
da un'interfaccia utente rivoluzionaria
e lì è la prima volta che sentiamo
l'interfaccia utente per cui il
coinvolgimento
da oggi in poi arriverà tramite questa
interfaccia utente attenzione pensiamo
che siamo nel nostro consiglio di
amministrazione del nostro brand
non è mica nostro lo smartphone è di
qualcun altro come lo usiamo
oddio poi c'è la app store
dove altri dieci brand possono costruire
quelle piccole icone che sembrano tutte
uguali e per il consumatore non cambiano
per cui come facciamo a coinvolgere a
contribuire a crescere a capire dove ci
posizioniamo e qui si complica ancora di
più
vi ricordate i giovani davide con le
fionde arrivano le start up arrivano i
giovani che in un garage inventano un
idea
oddio pensate in questo consiglio di
amministrazione panico
cominciano a pensare cosa facciamo se
ecco quello con le idee
questa è l'idea geniale incubatori e
acceleratori call for ideas inspire call
for ideas techno science park e chi più
ne ha più ne metta
tutte attività che teoricamente servono
per raccogliere queste idee e magari
capire come usarle però non funziona non
funziona perché ci sono
netflix e blockbuster non li capisce tra
cui va in bancarotta non funziona perché
wall mara non si è reso conto di che
cosa faceva amazon non funziona perché
tutti fanno acceleratori incubatore
attività ma la fine non si riesce a
capire come usufruire di queste nuove
tecnologie
facciamo un passo avanti
siamo nel 2011 barry waksman c strategy
90 barjie e io penso una delle agenzie
digitali più avanti che ci sono state
lavorato con nike e lavorato con google
esce con questo concetto di integrazione
funzionale che già ha un senso di
dinamismo rispetto al vecchio pensiero
orizzontale verticale funzione che cos'è
questa funziona funziona un prodotto un
servizio che tramite le tecnologie
integrato per cui tutti i prodotti
queste funzioni lavorano insieme sono
connesse e questo il modo con cui i
brand e moderni riescono a costruire
valore e monetizzare più di quelli
tradizionali
la cosa intelligente che hanno
identificato le quattro tecnologie base
voi avete sentito aiuti si parla di
tante cose però in questo momento
storico si dice che ci sono quattro cose
alla fine ci sono i sensori che
mobilizzano dati c'è questa famosa
claudio che l'archivio dei dati poi c'è
l'intelligenza artificiale che lavora i
dati
e poi c'è il nostro famoso smartphone
siamo sempre lì non cambia niente per
cui modo dei brand e capire come
utilizzare tutto questo però fermi tutti
e l'uomo siamo partiti dicendo che
disegneremo il nostro futuro
partiti dicendo che l'uomo al centro di
questo processo per cui dov'è finito
dov'è in questo quadro altro passo
avanti 2016 cinque anni di notte passate
con queste palline a muoverla destra ma
anche cercare di capire come questo
sistema funziona e finalmente una notte
immagino la mangiando patatine scrivendo
sul rotoloni di carta igienica
finalmente arriva l'idea è l'intento che
deve cambiare
e l'intento in quel consiglio di
amministrazione che da oggi in poi non
deve essere più che cosa dobbiamo fare
ma è che cosa il nostro consumatore
vuole per cui queste tecnologie
diventano lo strumento per capire che
cosa vuole siamo noi che decidiamo il
nostro futuro
giusto per cui la tecnologia diventa un
layer che ci permette di comunicare
qualsiasi cosa ci sia dall'altra parte
da un lato semplice permettetemi di
legarmi al tema di stasera
prima di passare a oggi liberi di essere
grandi
io sono uno di quelli che sostiene che
la libertà è una gentile fusione di
diritti e di doveri e quando ci sono
queste trasformazioni così radicale
della società
ritengo che la democrazia debba avere un
ruolo fondamentale
nel guidare la società in questo
percorso di comprensione facendoli
collaborare facendoli lavorare insieme è
un po come il regista in una squadra di
calcio e quello che non sei né gol e
quello che non pare gol e quello che non
fa la copertina sulla gazzetta però
senza di lui il team non va avanti
e arriviamo oggi il giorno in cui la
repubblica più vecchia del mondo ha
avuto fiducia in un tecnico un po
visionario come me ha avuto fiducia che
in questo territorio si possa cominciare
a pensare così si possa cominciare a
cercare di mettere ordine a questo
processo di innovazione si possa pensare
di mettere l'uomo al centro di questo
percorso e far collaborare tutti nel
disegnare questo futuro che alla fine
dipende solo da noi vogliamo essere
liberi di essere grandi o no anche
perché poi le cose si complicheranno
quando arrivano le stampe tra i il posto
stampare qualsiasi cosa in casa come li
certifico questi prodotti un bambino un
po cadere su una sedia che mi sono
stampate in casa cosa succede quali sono
le regole
la legge come risponde poi la politica
la politica che comincia a diventare
digitale la brook chain la genetica e
stavamo sentendo parlare prima
sono tutte cose in cui senza delle
regole senza un lavoro di collaborazione
tra la società e la democrazia non si
riuscirà a capire come questo funzionerà
come questo ci permetterà di gestire le
idee perché alla fine il futuro saranno
le vostre idee
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]